start making connections so I'm a big
believer that the easiest way to sell
your product or service is to connect
with people who are already selling to
your target base the hardest thing to do
is to go one at a time one at a time one
at a time trying to deal with potential
customers with the easiest thing to do
is partner up with individuals and
businesses who already know your target
audience who already have the audience
themselves and can introduce you to them
then by introducing yourself to one
person you're reaching potentially
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands and millions of people so how
this relates to my book I'm just
starting to get into the marketing side
of things we're just finishing up the
copy edits it's in the publishers hand
right now and I don't have anything else
to write so I'm kind of sitting like
this on Tuesdays so okay I'm gonna start
making some connections starting in the
marketing side rolling a little bit and
for me you know when the book comes out
I'm obviously gonna tell you guys about
it hopefully you guys were supportive
but after that I don't want to just go
try to reach people one at a time the
strategy is gonna be partnering up with
people making alliances with people who
are also have a big audience for them to
help promote it share it ask questions
so on the channel I've already done
collaborations with Michael Gerber and
Brian Tracy there's some new ones coming
up soon with Ryan holiday and Chris
Gulabo and Lewis Howes and Gary
Vaynerchuk and then working my way into
James Altucher Tony Robbins Robert
Greene and a bunch of other authors and
influencers and so the strategy is I
want to get on their radar I want to
have them on my channel I want to
interview them get to know them a little
bit more I just came back from New York
where I met Ryan and then Chris was here
on on Monday and then when I'm ready to
go right like you give first I'm helping
them promote what they're doing and then
when my book comes out they're gonna be
having me on their podcast at their
interviews or their YouTube channel or
whatever however we work it out and so
it's really important like you want to
start making those connections start
making those alliances because it's the
it's a lot easier to set up a
partnership call and Alliance call if
you guys can help each other out then
just trying to go do a sales call and
the potential influence is much
because these guys can help impact you
and introduce you to thousands of people
instead of one at a time so start
thinking about who you can make
connections with in your business to
help you really expand and grow so stick
to the questions first one came in from
Rita
there's no way anyone else could read it
the way you do not to mention most
readers want the connection with the
author yeah last time I was talking
about how we do have an e-book coming
out and an audio book coming out I'm
gonna be able to read the audio book and
again I haven't talked my publisher
about it but I'm assuming they're gonna
want me to do it for the e-book it's
gonna be a deluxe ebook that also has a
half an hour of video in there so I got
to figure out what kind of bonus thirty
minutes of footage I can fit in I may
ask you guys for feedback once we
release the the title and the concept
because it's kind of hard without know
what it's all about but yeah there's a
lot of love going in you know my
publisher said this is an option but
you're gonna have to spend the time to
create and edit the videos like that's
not a problem I'm willing to work like I
will work I will make the videos I will
record all of the audiobook I'm gonna
put in the hustle nobody else is gonna
do it like I will do it as soon as
that's ready I'll let you guys now Keith
soon a goddess I love this episode you
have been a great inspiration and
motivation for me thank you for that I
have a question I have a fear of failing
and leaving my comfort zone every time I
want to try to draw panels and pages for
my manga I freeze up and end up just
looking at the sketchbook or tablet I
fear that I will fail and mess it up
I've never done it before so I'd be
leaving my comfort zone - how do you get
the motivation to leave your comfort
zone and not be afraid to mess up or
fail I think the key thing there one you
know totally understand totally get it
everybody faces that I remember when I
was first doing videos for the YouTube
channel I was afraid that I would suck
and then I filmed it and I thought that
I did suck that's anything like anything
new that is exciting for you there's
also that attachment of fear but if you
don't go out and do it then you're just
gonna keep living the life that you have
right now and never do anything exciting
the interesting or challenging for
yourself at least will help for me is
expecting to suck so I don't see you
know if I were you I wouldn't see my
first mangas trying to be amazing like
you have these expectations for you want
to be up here but your skills aren't
there to match right you know what is
good but your skills can't measure up
yet
but you get better every day my goal is
always to create something better than I
did yesterday right if I looked at my
channel and said well listen I'm not
Tony Robbins and I look at Tony Robbins
if like he's maybe one of the best
series or Les Brown or Eric Thomas I'm
not that guy so I'm not gonna get
started that will prevent me from
getting as far as I have and if you look
at the start of my channel to where it
is now you see me get a lot better and
have a lot more impact and this helped
people like you and so there were people
who will appreciate what you have just
focus on making it better every day
because as long as you keep that blank
page daily you're never gonna learn you
never gonna get better you're always
gonna be afraid draw something and then
draw something tomorrow and then draw
something the next day and just focus on
making it better each day instead of
looking at the people who are the best
and saying I'm not like them and I suck
expect to be terrible at the start and
get better every day relaxing sleep
station wrote in to say for me
audiobooks are much easier to consume
and would be eager to hear yours when
the time comes keep changing lives thank
you for that and yeah I'm not a big
consumer of audiobooks but I know a lot
of people are especially people who
commute a lot I think because I don't
commute to work I don't really listen to
audiobooks but it may just be a personal
preference thing but yes we now set a
number of months ago I believe on the
channel super excited to do it and as
soon as it's ready to go I don't know
the timing of when the audiobook is
gonna come out how much it matches with
the actual book if it all comes together
or there's a delay or not but as soon as
that's ready to go I'll let you guys
know Martin Macedonian is asking
multi-level marketing is it a scam
multi-level marketing is just a business
model right Melton love marketing
network marketing is just a business
model the scam is not in the business
model this game would be in the
companies but it's just as much of a
scam as in anything else right I could
open up a business online and pretend to
sell you something they're never
actually ship it so it's not that MLM is
necessarily a scam it just depends on
the companies that you end up working
with I would say though you want to work
with the company the biggest flaw is
people go in just they can they make a
lot of money where what you want to do
is focus on a product or service that
you actually use that you love that you
can tell a story about that you would
recommend to your mother that we tell
your friends to use because it's adding
so much value to your life if you do not
actually use the product I can't
about it in a in a personal emotional
way then you're never gonna have success
so some people may say MLM is a scam
it's not it's just a business model just
like anything else it's the companies
that are behind it and some are gonna be
great and some are gonna be bad just
like any other industry next up is
Shubham asking hope you get my message
I'm pretty messed up with a situation
I'm a college student and not even
financially strong this sort of business
but of a startup idea and I've even made
a team for that
it's an event organizing company I mean
online event organization company so I'm
pretty confused shall I start this
business or not many have demoralized me
regarding this and many have motivated
me but my heart does not listen to
anyone else I just want to start this
business this month do you have any
piece of advice for me I'll be glad to
follow that thank you this is a great
question I want to thank a lot of people
can relate to I think when you come up
with an idea there's gonna be a lot of
people who hate on it there's gonna be a
lot of people to tell you you can't do
it say well you've never run an event
organization company so you won't be
successful and it's great that you act
you have some people around you who are
motivating you and that you are at the
end of they're gonna listen to yourself
because too many people live somebody
else's version of their lives instead of
their own version right you can take
counsel from people but at the end of
the day you're making a decision because
the right thing for you in your heart
not because somebody else thinks you
should do it in terms of getting started
you just want to find the smallest
easiest way to get started right it's
great that you have a team it's great
that you have partners who are helping
you out on this this is a business that
is very time intensive but doesn't have
to be very capital intensive which is
great because you have a lot of time but
you don't have a lot of money so you're
not out spending tons of cash building
inventory buying equipment getting
vehicles getting locations right you
need you don't need to have pay rent or
do anything else you can start with just
your hustle and any business you can
start with just your hustle is a perfect
business to get started so start try it
see if it's for you see if it makes you
come alive see if you enjoyed see what
the customer reaction is you know you
may get into it and it may be the best
thing that ever happened to you when you
go all-in and you have an amazing career
you may get into it and you hate it you
figure out you know what it wasn't what
I thought it was I don't want to do this
I'm gonna go off and do something else
and that's a great learning experience
as well you need to get some answers and
the only way to do it
is to do it so start last question is
Julian I have a YouTube channel which
covers my songs but some people tell me
Julian you should record recent songs or
songs we hear on the radio and this is
my question must I record recent songs
even if I don't like them just because
people listen to them for example I
recorded Unchained Melody from the movie
Ghost I love the song and people love
the song - so is this a combination you
were talking about this is an
interesting question and and I'm glad to
you you asked it because there's a lot
of different ways to grow a business
there's a lot of different I'd advice
you can get from people I can give you a
lot of different marketing strategies
but you have to figure out which is the
one that works for you so I think as
musicians it is super easy to do your
own take on songs right if you took a
lady Gaga song or you know some super
popular song right now and put your own
twist on it that's the easiest way to
stand out compared to creating original
work
you know Unchained Melody is a well
known song maybe a little bit dated but
if you love it and that's what's going
to make you come alive you're gonna put
a lot more energy into it then if you
try to do a cover of a song that you're
not a big fan of and so it may be the
best strategy in the world but if your
heart isn't into it then it's not gonna
work for you right if I said go make a
cover of thrift shop and you hate thrift
shop then it's not gonna be a great
cover and it's not going to help you so
you got to find the songs that you do
like whether it's create an original
work or if you're gonna do covers
finding the ones that you do really
enjoy like Unchained Melody and keep
going all in on that it'd be great to
see your take on it right as an artist
you got to figure out what you're
bringing what your creative expression
is so that when somebody listen to it
they feel something right the point of
art is that when I listen to your music
or when I see your painting or when I
you know see you dancing or whatever it
is I get moved emotionally and the only
way for me to be moved emotionally is
for you to be moved emotionally when you
are creating it so if you're not moved
emotionally then don't create it and
spend your time doing the stuff that
does move you so thank you guys so much
for watching if you have a question
about the topic which was about creating
connections or you want to learn about
my book or question about the book
writing process leave it in the comments
below and I will answer you in next week
thank you guys so much for watching and
thank you for your support
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon